this was snap's trajectory for most of
2021 its Share value was steadily moving
up and the company was posting record
revenue and launching new initiatives
Off the Grid and off the leash at by
September its stock price had
skyrocketed over 700 percent from its
low point in 2020 but in October 2021
snap stock began to slip since then its
Share value has fallen over 80 percent
and in August snap announced that they
will cut 20 of their Workforce
discontinue investments in snap
Originals minis games and pixie so what
went wrong
it all started in April 2021. Apple
announced these changes to its privacy
policy that said apps now have to ask
users if they want to be tracked
according to mobile app analytics
provider flurry U.S users opt into
tracking only about 16 percent of The
Times They encounter Apple's privacy
prompt this makes it more difficult for
advertisers to Target their ads at the
Right audience and get information about
how well their ads performed the impact
of Apple's changes showed up six months
later when snap posted Revenue growth
numbers that fell short of what
investors and analysts were expecting
its stock price dropped over 20 percent
in after hours trading that day other
social media companies like Facebook's
parent meta also took a hit from Apple's
privacy changes but snap is a smaller
company that brings in less Revenue to
begin with investors got a glimmer of
hope in February when snap posted its
first ever quarterly profit as a public
company but it was short-lived because a
few weeks later the Russian invasion has
begun the first of a myriad of
compounding factors that contributed to
snap's continued decline in 2022. snap
says it spent five million dollars
helping its team members in Ukraine and
as macroeconomic conditions deteriorated
advertisers pulled back spending
Snapchat while it might be a place where
advertisers are indeed putting their
money when they have money to spend it
might be one of the things that's going
to get cut when they're trying to pull
back meta which owns Facebook and
Instagram which have slightly older user
bases it's going to provide better
returns generally for advertisers
because older people are going to have
more disposable income Snapples also hit
particularly hard because the company
relies primarily on Direct response
advertising which are ads that are
intended to get users to immediately
click on or buy something
snap says this type of advertising is
easy to turn on and off and to scale
quickly with high return on investment
for advertisers but that works in the
opposite way when folks actually have to
reach their budgets and it's very easy
to
try snap doesn't report its admix but
has said that a significant majority of
its revenue is direct response related
this disruption in the digital ad Market
plus Apple's privacy changes the broad
effects of inflation and labor and
supply chain issues all sent snap over
the edge if it was one thing snot might
have been able to handle it but when you
have all these different things
happening at once Snapchat's getting hit
one thing after the other that's where
the company started to struggle in the
spring snap continued adding staff and
launching new initiatives including a
camera drone this is Pixie a
pocket-sized friendly free-flying camera
and a Content push for its original
scripted videos this is daring Simone
biles despite its new products snap's
Share value continued to Tumble and in
late may snap told investors that its
Revenue growth numbers were likely going
to come in lower than expected profit
warnings are not something that
companies just give out willy-nilly and
so the fact that they did this was it
was quite a big deal actually following
this announcement snaps load hiring and
spending the company had previously
added staff at Breakneck speed during
the pandemic growing its head count by
around 65 percent since the end of 2020.
snap also brought on two Executives to
specifically address the challenges from
Apple's privacy changes but analysts say
they still expect snap to post a hefty
net loss this quarter in August snap
announced it was shutting down future
development of its flying selfie drone
pixie which it had launched less than
four months earlier and then two weeks
later they announced that they were
going to lay off 20 of their staff and
shut down many more projects that
weren't core to its business around that
same time Netflix poached snaps Chief
business officer and Vice President of
Sales for the Americas to kick-start its
ad supported subscription plan snap
declined to comment at the code
conference in September snap CEO
responded to questions about a possible
takeover saying I believe that the best
way to realize our long-term potential
is by building an independent company
and I think you know while the stock
price has gone up and down over time we
have slowly and steadily increased the
long-term value of our best business
looking ahead snap says it expects the
cost cutting measures to reduce the
company's annual costs by around 500
million dollars snap says it's also
working to diversify its ad business by
monetizing features like Spotlight which
tries to appeal to content creators
snap says it's also working to monetize
My Places which offers users
personalized recommendations of places
to eat and visit the company also
launched Snapchat Plus a subscription
service that gives users early and
exclusive access to features for 3.99 a
month analysts investors myself we're
all watching to see is the additional ad
business recovering
um are they diversifying their business
if something happens again to the
digital ad Market will it not affect
them as much in the future snap has been
through difficult times before the
question again is whether it can snap
back
[Music]